when you were in college yeah is that
where you met Lauren Hill yeah I was in
college I was uh it was my it was the
spring of my junior year
and I was directing this church choir
actually up in Scranton Pennsylvania
which is like an hour and a half north
of Philly right and I would go up there
every weekend and direct this church
choir and one of the girls in the choir
grew up with Lauryn Hill and was friends
with her and was like you should come to
Jersey and meet Lauren she's making her
album I want you to meet her so I went
to uh this is when she was making the
miseducation Miss education Lauryn Hill
she'd already done the big album with
the Fugees the score and everyone was
like oh Lauryn Hill's gonna do a solo
album I want to hear what this sounds
like and she was making a miseducation
were you a fan of hers from the Fuji's
yes I was she they had come and played a
big concert at my school like a couple
years before that I think it was amazing
yeah she's awesome yeah and so uh I went
to the studio it was over here in like
you know South Orange or East Orange one
of the oranges right and uh you know I
went to the studio she was in the house
is that intimidating for you when
someone says I was intimidated I just
sat in the corner and was just kind of
quiet so you meet her yeah and you ended
up working on her record right I end up
in that moment uh my friend was like
John you got to play a song for her let
her hear how you sing and play so I
played a song for her would you play for
Lauren Hill I'm saying a Stevie Wonder
song called Love's in Need and I played
a original song that I did called uh
it's too late so was that your first
really big payday the Lauren Hill
Experience no man I got 500 for that so
I you don't get a piece of the action on
the record no because I didn't write
anything I just played on it so it's
just a session fee okay so and I didn't
even know it was going to make the
session I didn't know the song was going
to make the album I didn't know my piano
was going to make the song she took that
song that you played for her and is that
the one she put on the record no she was
already working on a song right and she
had written it with the people in the
room and she just asked me to play piano
on it and so the first song I ever
played on a major album was Everything
is Everything oh one of this educational
that's a great song right it's a great
song oh yeah well and and I told her you
know my real name is John Stevens by the
way so uh you know I I at the time
didn't have a stage name and whatever
and I didn't know if my song was going
to make the album I get a call all like
months later from Sony asking for the
correct spelling of my name and that's
when I actually knew it was going to be
on the album and I was like John R
Stevens so if you look in the
miseducation Lauren Hill you'll see a
credit for piano by John R Stevens